Silicon Valley I love this plot twist  this season your character Dinesh  becomes the CEO and I love this because  it's so true to your character you  immediately when you become CEO start  putting product in your hair that's how  you handle getting great power I feel  like I've become whatever Dinesh thinks  is the best version of him and he has  this like really crazy hairdo we have I  think we have a picture maybe of your  layer you're putting it's like a John  Stamos not like a John Stamos thing  Charlie Sheen John Stamos been going  yeah I just figured you know whenever  someone like gets power they get like a  crazy hair like kim jeong-hoon or hitler  or you know  right so we're out of time  [Laughter]  you